thanks so much it's a real thrill to be
here today to talk to you about how
things are evolving in understanding
human disease using genetic approaches
and tools so what I want to talk about
first is how I got interested in science
this is the family I was born into my
mom dad and older brother that's me and
Lakota in the upper right my dad was
says you can see was in the Air Force
and I was moved around along with the
family we lived all over the United
States and abroad we lived in Turkey for
a couple of years when I was growing up
and my exposure to science was just
through interest in what was going on in
school and I became really interested in
the ideas of I was inspired by President
Kennedy in the 1960s to want to do
something beyond myself medicine seemed
like a great outlet seemed like a very
good intersection between science and
helping people and as I became further
involved in medicine it became clear to
me that a lot of the limitations in
medicine where every really didn't
understand the basic biology of how
humans normally work and how disease
processes and changed the normal biology
of
humans to cause disease and so I
developed a career of pursuing the
interface between basic science and
clinical medicine with the notion that
the better we understand the fundamental
causes of disease the better we'll be
able to ultimately develop new
approaches to the diagnosis prevention
and treatment of disease and being a
scientist at a great place like Yale is
one of the joys that one could possibly
have and you get to work with incredibly
smart people these are people who have
trained in my laboratory who have now
gone out and run their own laboratory
ole for the united's in the world and
that's a great thrill and opportunity
and you also get to work with incredibly
smart people as a scientist and the
number of people just here at Yale who
have collaborated with over the years is
just extraordinary and involve people in
virtually every basic science and
clinical dept I here at the University
and so being a scientist and being a
physician is something that I got just
one of the great opportunities to
discover something new about how humans
work and that is a profoundly satisfied
we also get to have a family and this is
my family who have been born and raised
here in New Haven my wife and three kids
and so I want to just underscore the
point that though there is life in
science and outside science and Bofur
compatible what I want to start with is
how we have come to understand that
genetics is important in human biology
and I want to start with the point that
as long as humans have been on the
planet we have recognized the
fundamental principle that light begets
like and so if you want to have giraffes
you need a male and a female giraffe and
we're to get
knew giraffes if you want to have
ostriches you need to have a male and a
female ostrich to produce new ostriches
we have recognized this principle as
long as humans have been on planet and
so we have known something about
genetics that this principle of life it
gets light is really what underscores
the fundamentals of genetic and we also
recognize that this applies not just to
animals but to humans as well so here is
an apocryphal family of four pairs of
identical twins and in the absence of
genetic variation identical twins are
identical because they share a complete
set of the identical chromosomes they
come from the same fertilized egg and as
a consequence if you look at these four
pairs of individuals you will recognize
that they don't sort of look like one
another they look indistinguishable from
one another their overall shape height
weight where the weight is distributed
is identical but those are just gross
features they're really fine features of
their hair color their smile virtually
identical and I don't think any of us if
we saw these pairs would have any
difficulty recognizing that these are
genetic clones of one another and are
virtually identical in their physical
appearance now of course we don't all
look like one another there's tremendous
variation in human traits and this is a
beautiful photograph by a famous
photographer Annie Leibovitz that
demonstrates this point this is a jockey
of a really shoemaker who wrote many
winners in the Kentucky Derby and the
basketball player Wilt Chamberlain who
played Center for the Los Angeles Lakers
now I don't think any of us in this room
would likely believe that even if we are
the most ardent proponents of the idea
that it's nurture rather than nature
that
we end up I think even in the extreme
case we would have a hard time believing
that if Wilton Willy's parents had
exchanged their children at birth that
Willie would have been the wind to grow
up to play center for the Lakers and
will would have been the one riding and
got horses in the Kentucky Derby and of
course when we look around this room we
walk around New Haven on this beautiful
fall afternoon we see that there's
tremendous diversity in human
appearances but we also recognize that
it's not lightly just human appearances
that are determined by genes the genes
are also influencing our susceptibility
to virtually every disease otherwise how
could we explain the paradox of Jim Fixx
and Winston Churchill so Jim Fixx was
five minute and 150 pounds Winston
Churchill 518 perhaps on a day 270
pounds it fixed was a marathon runner
Churchill was slow flow by his own
description legendary for his gluttony
at the dinner table so if fix was also a
healthy lifestyle promoter Churchill was
a smoker of fine cigars and from
everything we know about lifestyle we
would have said fixes leading the
healthy lifestyle Churchill is leading a
lifestyle that should lead to early
demise from a variety of ailments so
despite stacking the deck in this
fashion how can we explain that fix in
fact is the one who died at age 52 while
running a cautionary note to those of us
in this age group but Churchill despite
all these adverse risk factors lives in
the ripe old age of 90 well of course
fix had something going against him from
the outset and this is something that we
all recognize that disease is frequently
we say run in families and what we mean
by saying it is
runs and families is that if somebody in
your family has a particular disease you
are somewhat more likely than anyone in
the general population to also have that
disease and it fixes case he had this
genetic predisposition that his father
died of a heart attack at a very young
age of 43 and so we have suspected from
families like this that there are
unlocked there are likely to be genetic
factors that are contributing to the
risk of disease but until the last 20
years or so we've had almost no ability
to use that information to understand
what those underlying causes might be so
how have we gotten to a state where
today we can actually begin to
understand these problems in human
populations well this all dates back to
about 150 years ago when Gregor Mendel a
monk in Austria began an interesting
series of experiments of breeding
different varieties of peas together and
what he recognized that there were there
were some very unexpected outcomes of
the kinds of breeding that he did and he
thought for example that if he bred
people plants that only produced Rockies
and those that only produce wrinkled
peas all of the offspring only produce
round peas but if he then make further
breeding between those offspring he
found that reproducibly 75% of the
offspring produced only ground teams
inch but 25% produced wrinkled peas and
he found the same kind of pattern
occurring with different traits in his
crosses and this led him to recognize
that there were factors he had no idea
what those factors were that were being
transmitted from the
of pea plants to their offspring that
were then segregating has discrete
factors so that and he deduced that in
this case in this case in this cross
there were two different versions of
this factor will call them plus and
minus and if you inherited one or two
versions of the plus factor you always
produce round piece and if you but only
if you had two of the minus versions did
you get wrinkle piece he had no idea
what these factors were but he could
deduce that they were being transmitted
in an unmodified form from generation
after generation and it's but
statistically 25% of the offspring of a
cross where you have one copy of the
plus one copy of the minus allele you
would get offspring that were only
wrinkled so from this we developed an
idea that there are these factors that
were being transmitted in an unmute
abbud mutated form from generation to
generation and these were determining
determining the phenotypes in this case
of these pink plants the next big step
in the evolution of genetics came from
the recognition of where these factors
resided in the cell so the cells were
known at that time and it was known that
inside the nucleus of cells there are
these things called chromosomes and it
was recognized that the number of
chromosomes was different species to
species and in some animals the number
was different in male and female animals
and this ultimately led Thomas so Morgan
a geneticist who worked on fruit flies
to prove that these factors that mental
had identified it resided on chromosomes
inside the nuclei of cells and his
pivotal experiment was to cross fruit
flies one that had red eyes one that had
white eyes and what he found
was that in this cross the white eyes
always traveled with the same with the
chromosome that was determining mail
sacks and so as a consequence in this
cross the light metals p cross the first
set of offspring all had red eyes but
was only when you made it these to one
another that he produced offspring where
there were flies but 75% had red eyes
twenty-five percent had white eyes and
the wide-eyed flies were always male and
this provided the fellow proof that the
factor for white eyes was traveling on
the chromosomes inside the nuclei of
cells and that was an enormous advance
in our understanding but at that time we
still did not know what is it in those
in the chromosomes we knew that the
chromosomes contain DNA and protein it
was commonly thought at that time that
the DNA could possibly be the genetic
material because there are only four
different fundamental molecule types in
DNA and there a different basis it will
call them a G C and T and it was thought
to be such a simple chemical polymer
that it couldn't possibly account for
all of the factors that we believed
existed in individual species and the
pivotal experiment that proved that DNA
in fact was the genetic material came
from an experiment that Griffith did in
the 1920s where there are two strains of
bacteria one of which was virulent and
would would kill mice when injected in
mice one of which were not and what
Griffith first show was that you could
kill heat treat and thereby kill the
Brenda bacteria but mix them with the
non burial and bacteria and ended up
killing the mice nonetheless which that
it was just infected with the non
virulent bacteria and if you took the
bacteria that came out of that they were
now very so something had been
transferred from the virulent bacteria
despite the fact that they were dead so
it had to be some chemical that got into
the non virulent bacteria and made them
Miriam and Avery and others in the 1940s
proved that that stuff was DNA and that
proved the DNA linking all the way back
to Mendel was accounting for the factors
that are accounting for transmission of
variation and traits from generation to
generation and that had left the mystery
of how is it that DNA could possibly
provide the code and Watson and Crick
demonstrated that DNA is a double helix
shown here that's composed of these
forms versions a G C and T and as you
unwind this healer you can see that
they're always paired in a way that a is
paired with T G is paired with T in the
two strands of DNA and we have learned
that this in fact is what accounts for
how all proteins are made inside the
cell and proteins are the business end
of the genome and are what are
responsible for all the day-to-day
chemistry and metabolism that occurs
inside the cell so that if this is our
double-stranded DNA a card with TG Paris
see this is the library that sits inside
the nucleus and it's copied in various
bits comb by the process called
transcription into RNA copies and the
RNA copies provide the code for which
dry which all proteins are made inside
the cell and there are ribosome
inside a cell to do this translation
process and Tom States here at Yale won
the Nobel Prize for determining the
structure of these ribosomes that are
these proteins that are responsible for
making a whole of the proteins in
themself so I just want to stop for a
moment and make the point of how amazing
this entire process is and these
chromosomes sit inside the nucleus
they're replicated generation after
generation and this is the Watson and
Crick recognized that this explained the
fundamental mechanism of how is it that
we go from generation to generation with
our traits being passed in a faithful
for two subsequent generations because
when these two strands are replicated at
you separate the two strands and the
sequence of each strand provides the
complement of the sequence of the other
and so you can come up with the
identical sequence of the two strands
simply by separating them and
replicating them and this accounts for
how we're capable of passing the same
sequence from generation to generation
and this is really a profound insight
that is the great fundamental basis for
how we think about the consistency of
life across generations you can imagine
however that occasionally mistakes might
be made so that rather than faithfully
replicating this sequence you might make
a mistake and the replication process is
extremely faithful but on average
there's about one mistake in every 50
million five hundred million bases and
as a consequence this is incredibly
faithful but the process but sometimes
makes errors and these errors are how
variation is introduced into the
population
and accounts for why we don't all look
like one another but also accounts for
our susceptibility to a variety of
diseases I also just want to take a
point to going to make the point of how
amazing it is how chromosomes are
wrapped up inside the nucleus cell so in
mitosis when cells are dividing we have
to make precise copies of the
chromosomes and then pass each cap one
copy of each of the offspring
chromosomes onto each daughter cell as
cells divide and replicate and to
demonstrate how amazing this folding
process is I'll need some volunteers so
i will think i'll need nine volunteers
from the audience so who wants to come
up and help me come on up well i need
some more c'mon c'mon c'mon I need a few
were yeah please come on up yeah please
come up okay so come up right here okay
so let me first is I'm going to need
some more so come on out okay so is this
looks like a good group one hey you need
two more come on
one more now just one okay so I want to
make the point that if I if I picked my
finger with a pin and took a drop of
blood I would have 5,000 in a drop of
blood and then that makes about a
hundred microliters of blood and in that
hundred microliters of blood there would
be about 500,000 white blood cells and
if I took it down to one microliter of
blood there would be about 5,000 white
blood cells so this is what you would
see in a microscope and these are the
red blood cells which have no DNA and no
nuclei and these are the white blood
cells in deccan of inside the drop of
blood and if I just took a hundred cells
and unraveled all of the human DNA in
that in those under it sells what I have
here is the length of what those hundred
cells would look okay so I want you to
come over here and stand here and I want
you to stand over here and I want you to
do the unschooling I want you to take
this now are you
the stand right there and now I'll need
to do this two more times so I want some
a stick here once your grapes in here
okay and you grab this in and you grab
the spool and you go up the stairs about
halfway up and we'll do the same thing
over here come on over okay so you hold
this you take the spool and you run up
the stairs down way ok and now watch
says you come over here and come further
down ok so I want you to take the school
and bring it to Ferb come on down
unravel it you're going to have to go
fast ok and give it to her and you grab
the string now grab the string and you
go back and once you go back and forth
until the entire school this fool down I
want you to do the same thing so this is
how long and go ahead and this is the
DNA they'll go back and forth just back
and forth and you're going to have to go
fast because there's a lot of DNA and it
so there are three billion bakers in the
human genome and the three billion base
pairs when unschooled in a hundred cells
it comes out to over 600 feet and it's
all wound up inside a single cell that
is only 10 microns in land in diameter
and it's astounding how well that's
packed and in fact if we took all of the
cells in the human genome fit in the
human body of which there perhaps thirty
trill
we would find that the length of DNA
laid end-to-end would extend to the Sun
and back three hundred times so just
think about how amazing the compassion
of DNA inside the cell how's everybody
doing we have a lot of strands going
back and forth and I think we're going
to have to go faster
everybody's doing an amazing job and I
think we're figuring out just how long
this is in keep in mind this is just the
DNA from but hundred cells inside the
body telly you dropped one and this is
where we get to the point where I think
we could declare victory and say we have
proved our point that the DNA inside
ourselves is incredibly long in each
cell doesn't one cell it's about six
feet in length for all of the
chromosomes and when we put it all
together for a hundred self of being
about 600 feet in length which is
malinka peaceful so I think we should I
say yep it's very long and that you've
done an awesome job
put it on up here so just come on down
and put it up here it's great guys did
great thank you very much for your help
so starting in 1985 there was utter
after yourself thank you there was an
audacious idea that was proposed as a
science experiment and the basic idea
was that we would make tremendous
progress in understanding biology if we
were able to if we were able to sequence
the genome of humans and determine the
DNA sequence of all three billion bases
of the human genome and that was an
audacious idea in particular because we
had no idea how we could actually
achieve that goal at the time but
remarkably this was told off in about 15
years and in 2001 and then 2003 a draft
and the complete sequence was published
and that gave us the blueprint of what
it takes to make a human being and
surprisingly people had guests before
the three billion bases were sequenced
how many protein coding genes would
there be in the human genome and the
guesses ranged from a low of about
15,000 to a high of about 220,000 and
most people guessed around 50,000 genes
it turned out that the answer is about
20,000 protein coding genes but the
second part that was really surprising
is that as other genomes were sequenced
it turns out that the number of genes
and the identity of genes in all
vertebrate species from fish humans is
pretty much the same number and they're
pretty much the same genes and as a
consequence this tells us that virtually
all genes are conserved their present
over
million years of evolution and their
preferred relatively they're generally
identical in their overall function from
species to species with a few exceptions
like gene families that are evolving
rapidly such as the immune system well
this led to the question of if that's
true could we understand how mutations
are contributing to disease and this of
course assumes that we can find genes
and tricks that are caused by genetic
factors and the evidence that this is
true is that there are rare diseases
that recur in families much more often
than expected by chance sometimes we can
find diseases that are prevalent in
particular parts of the world where
people are all evolved from a small set
of common ancestors so called genetic
isolates and then sometimes we find
trees are so unusual that they strongly
suggest a genetic causation and then
lastly we can find disease frequently
that diseases are more common in twins
who share a hundred percent of their
genes than twins normally share
dizygotic twins only share fifty percent
of their genes and from this we can
deduce that virtually every human
disease has a genetic contribution
sometimes from a single gene that whose
mutation causes the trade but more
commonly from multiple genetic variants
that are likely together causing
variation in the trade and so we see
families like this which would be caused
by a mutation in a single copy and a
single genes in which affected
individuals transmit the gene to half of
their offspring who get the trait and
the end of
do not get the gene end up remaining
three of the tray and this would be a
so-called dominant disease or recessive
disease is where each of the parents
carries one copy of the disease-causing
mutation and only if you get two mutant
copies of the gene do you get the
disease and this would be caused called
a recessive trait so we have recognized
over the years that we can identify
these underlying genes and these can
help us understand the biology not just
in the individuals who have the disease
but other places can identify mutations
and pathways that can be exploited in
the general population and I will give
you the example of a disease called
familial hypercholesterolemia this is a
disease that is very rare it affects
about one in a million people but it
causes the affected individuals to have
very high cholesterol levels that are
exceedingly high compared to the general
population and these individuals are
recognized to get heart attacks before
the age of 30 something that is very
rare in the general population before
age 30 and this therefore established a
causal relationship between high
cholesterol and heart attacks and led to
the recognition that if we can lower
cholesterol we might be able to prevent
heart attacks not just in these patients
with this disease but in everybody and
that's proved to be the case and we now
are using medications called this
commonly called the statins to inhibit
the production of cholesterol by the
body with the recognition that this has
profound effects to lower cholesterol
and this is
particularly impactful for people who
are at high risk of heart attacks in the
general population and is a nice example
of how we can use genetics to develop
new therapies that are have impact in
the general population indications that
cause this disease prevent the normal
clearance of cholesterol and blood
through receptors in the river that
normally are involved in clearing
cholesterol and sweeping it up from the
bloodstream a second example of how this
understanding genetics is leading to new
therapies is the first gene that was
identified in the contemporary era of
genetics and this is gene for cystic
fibrosis so cystic fibrosis is a
pulmonary disease that causes children
who are affected with cystic fibrosis to
get chronic infections in their lungs
that frequently leads to complications
with pneumonia and often leads to death
at early ages the gene for cystic
fibrosis was identified in 1989 and was
identified to be a chloride channel that
is expressed in the cells that line the
lung they have a medium of the law and
the mutations cause this channel to no
longer work properly and this was an
example where the gene was identified
but at the time it was identified we had
absolutely no idea how to mitigate the
effects of that mutation but people
continued working on it and just in the
last several years
is developed medic medicine that can
allow patients who have cystic fibrosis
where the new channel gets to the cell
surface but no longer is capable of
opening normally well they've identified
a drug that is capable of opening these
channels and this has been shown to
improve lung function in patients with
cystic fibrosis and is a beautiful
example where we had no idea what the
underlying cause was the specific cause
was identified and medication has been
identified that can mitigate the effects
of the disease causing a mutation give
another example where the underlying
biology has revealed completely new
elements that have changed the way we
think about a common trait in the
population so we have recognized that
obesity is a gene environment
interaction and we have suspected that
there are genes that contribute to
obesity we also know that are above the
availability of calories in the
environment is important to the
development of obesity and here are two
strains of mice these are in fact two to
offspring of the same litter of my so
you can see one local mouse and one last
n is a little bit different it's a
little bit different in that it is a
massive has massive obesity and this is
all due to accumulation of body fat and
jeffrey friedman at Rockefeller
University demonstrated that this is
caused by the single mutation in a
protein called leptin and leptin his a
protein that is involved in it is made
in fat cells and what Jeff show is that
it is made in fat cells and is a hormone
that is exported from fat cells to tell
the brain how much energy there is how
much fat there is in the body as a
source of stored energy and so the
normal function of this pathway is to
tell the brain when the fat stores
full and to tell the brain as a
consequence to stop taking in more
calories because we've got plenty of
stored energy around and so these mice
develop this massive obesity because
they are no longer capable of making
that protein and sending that signal to
the brain to say stop eating well that
applies not just to mice but also to
humans who are missing leptin so here is
a three year old photograph of a three
year old and a seven year old this three
year old is about 160 pounds at age
three and if you ask his parents about
his dietary habits they will tell you
that they have tried locking the
refrigerator clearing all of the
cabinets of food and a child is just
relentless in his drive to eat and he
has achieved this impressive obesity at
age three he turns out to be genetically
deficient for being able to make this
hormone leptin and as a consequence this
profoundly I think changes the way we
think about obesity because this is not
a matter of will or you know how willing
somebody is to do something the absence
of this hormone is driving his drive to
eat and is not a matter of his personal
responsibility in that regard remarkably
this photograph of this seven year old
is the same individual after he has
received leptin for several years so
this wee one hormone has transformed
this child from massive obesity to now
having a perfectly normal body habitus
now this hormone does not have this
effect in the general population but for
these individuals this is a remarkable
finding and i think is profoundly
changed the way we think about obesity
in population i'll give one other
example of in the case of cancer so
there's a disease called chronic
myelogenous leukemia or CML which is a
cancer that has been uniformly fatal in
a human population for as long as we
have gin on the planet the course of the
disease has been that you're diagnosed
with chronic myelogenous leukemia you'll
smolder a long for a number of years and
after six or eight years it kicks off
into a much more Millennium page that
leads to death and this was a uniformly
fatal disease it was recognized that
there was a chromosome rearrangement
that a number of years ago was
demonstrated to cause increased activity
of a particular protein kinase called
table and the able kinase is a kinase
Azure proteins that transfer phosphate
groups on to other molecules and the
activity of this pathway in the white
blood cells that cause this leukemia
this leads to the increased
proliferation of the so
are involved in this leukemia and what
was the done by investigators working
with a pharmaceutical company was to
develop develop and show that a small
molecule called gleevec could inhibit
this kinase activity and prevent the
cell proliferation that results from the
activity of this kinase and we give it
to patients it's had a remarkable effect
of arresting the development of this
leukemia and patients commonly go into
long-term remission so that while there
were only about 6,000 individuals with
this disease in the population there are
now tens of thousands of individuals who
are surviving chronically with this
disorder but remained well as long as
they continue to take this drug because
the entire katha genesis of this
leukemia was driven by this one mutation
and that knowledge has led to new
therapeutics in our own group we've
worked on variety of diseases one of
these has been hypertension hypertension
is a major cause contributor to heart
attack and stroke it affects a billion
people worldwide and contributes to more
than 12 million deaths every year going
to heart attacks and strokes arising
from hypertension and pathogenesis has
been largely unknown we scoured the
world looking for individuals with the
highest and lowest forms of blood
pressures compatible with survival and
have used this to identify the
fundamental pathways that contribute to
hypertension that are relevant not just
to these rare patients but to the
general population it turns out that
there's one final pathway that is
regulated
that regulates blood pressure in humans
and that is how the kidney handles salt
so every day we have a million nephrons
in our kidneys and we filter about one
and a half kilos of salt and need to
reabsorb what about 1% of the filtered
load and that's done by a series of
transporters channels and exchangers and
we've identified mutations that cause
these extreme forms of high blood
pressure shown in red or low blood
pressure shown in blue and impressively
all of the single gene forms that dry
blood pressure to these extremes
converge on this final pathway that in
which and high blood pressure has caused
by mutations that increase salt
reabsorption low blood pressure is
caused by mutations that impair salt
reabsorption and the importance of this
is this as I dad has identified new
pathways to try to intervene with both
preventive and therapeutic strategies
and so now more than 30 countries around
the world have programs to reduce
dietary salt to reduce the incidence of
hypertension and heart disease the
Institute of Medicine in the United
States has explicitly proposed a way to
do this by reducing the level of salt in
processed foods and restaurant foods and
it's work as identified rational
treatments and based on these patients
with rare mutations that drive blood
pressures to the extremes so the
collective impact of this work is that
we now have about three thousand genes
with mutations that have been identified
that costs a human traits this is
transform our understanding of the
biology of every organ system in human
but this is not the end of the story so
the cost of DNA sequencing has been
dropping dramatically so we're proud of
pointing in to Moore's law and
computations where the cost of
memory doubles at the same cost about
every 18 months well the cost with DNA
sequencing has come down when we started
sequencing the human genome was 1998 it
cost a hundred thousand dollars to
sequence a million bases of DNA today it
costs about a penny to sequence a
million bases of DNA so this is
spectacular reduction in cost of DNA
sequencing has suggested that we ought
to be able to learn more from sequencing
genomes at a greater rate and so this
next generation of DNA sequencing each
machine DNA sequencer can produce about
500 million bases of DNA sequence per
day enough to provide complete sequence
of five human genomes it's done by a DNA
synthesis using these four different
colors for each of the four different
bases so it's not on the on tiny slides
where we should put 300 million spots
each from a clone of DNA and one base at
a time and the color of the base that is
identified by a microscope is capable of
telling us which base has been added at
each spot and as each spot grows we can
determine the sequence of DNA and this
is one of the slides that has that we do
these sequence reactions on and as you
can see they're tiny and have tiny
little channels on them in which we
introduce the DNA and do the sequencing
on the machines that I have shown you
I'll be glad to pass this around please
don't take it out of the container
because it's very sharp but on this we
can sequence 100
millions of basis of DNA on a daily
basis to do this at scale out on the
west campus just down the road from here
we set up the health center for genome
analysis we'll run the DNA sequencers we
have computer architecture they handled
the data as you can imagine the volume
of the data is extraordinary and we need
a very large data storage
high-performance computing capabilities
to manage the data over the last several
years we've sequenced the protein-coding
regions of more than 40,000 people to
study diverse disorders of human biology
so where should we be using this
technology what we know that they're
about 20,000 protein coding genes we
only know what happens when about 3,000
of these genes are mutated and there's a
consequence there's a lot that remains
to be done we expect that every human
gene went mutated except with a few
exceptions of highly repeated gene
families will have consequences when
these genes are mutated and so we
developed technology to allow us to
selectively sequence just the ones of
the genome that has these that encodes
the protein of coding parts of the
genome business end of the genome if you
will and so how are we using this
technology today well the first thing we
did was begin deploying this to make
diagnosis in people who were severely
ill who did not have a middle diagnosis
and this gives the example of the first
clinical diagnosis by this genome level
sequencing this was an individual
failure to thrive volume depletion was
unknown what his diagnosis was and we're
able to show that he had a mutation in
the gene that impaired his ability to
absorb the ion chloride in his colon
we'd gone to I use this to identify a
number of new diseases that were not
previously recognized for example this
individual had high fever and
respiratory failure and bleeding from a
number of sources of unknown cause it
was fun nothing stopping you might have
infectious cause and we ended up by DNA
sequencing showing that he had a
mutation that caused his disease that
defined a disease that was not
previously recognized in a gene that is
normally involved in the bacterial
response information and he had a
mutation that caused that to be kicked
off by other events such as physical or
emotional stress and as a consequence
this led to a massive outpouring of
proteins that cost his fever and
inflammation and he'll have been
recovered by being put on autos
immunosuppression and there are
medications that will suppress the
inflammatory molecules that he is making
on a chronic basis and can now be
treated and there are other families
like it that a system described around
the world we similarly identified
mutations that cause a variety of to
burn some of these tumors
actually maple hormones that we should
the common form of severe hypertension
caused by that megaphone aldosterone are
caused by mutations in an ion channel
that caused the channel to now rather
than only conduct a ion like potassium
can also conduct an eye on such as
sodium and then that end up causing the
cells to behave abnormally leading to
the Constituent production of this form
of and lead to severe hypertension and
these tumors occur in several million
people around the world and then more
recently we've recognized that we can
use this technology to identify diseases
that are genetic that we had never
really been sure before or genetic so
for example a range of congenital
diseases such as congenital heart
disease turn out to commonly be caused
by mutations that are absent in their
parents but are present in their
offspring so severe forms of congenital
heart disease require correction early
in life to sustain life and we've shown
that about ten percent of these cases
have new mutations that are absent the
parents that are present in the child
and a class of genes that are mediated
most frequently are genes that are
involved in the getting back to our
earlier point in wrapping chromosomes a
DNA into chromosomes inside cells and
there are a number of modifications of
these proteins that are involved in
opening up the chromosomes to allow
active transcription of the genes that
are contained in those segments and
mutations that are commonly being found
to cause congenital
disease are mutations that alter the
process of the modification of the
chromatin in which DNA is wrapped inside
cells and this is a quite surprising
finding that has come in the last couple
of years importantly this work is
leading to new therapeutics so in the
case of cancer we know that cancer is
commonly a disease of somatic mutation
mutations that are absent in our teams
when we're born but become mutated
during the course of our lifetime and
these are what are bribing the
development of these cancers so we now
recognize I told you about time
myelogenous leukemia there are mutations
in the epidermal growth factor receptor
in patients with lung cancer or which
they're announced that target the
specific limitation and there are other
example shown here along those lines
similarly targets produce air Phoenix
for pain for cholesterol for sweet for
Alzheimer's disease for osteoporosis and
a couple of the identification of rare
mutations that cause extreme forms of
bone abnormalities or earlier onset of
Alzheimer's disease I want to emphasize
this link between finding new insights
into therapeutic targets from
identifying rare patients with severe
forms of disease or power so this is
being rolled out on a national
national scale the NIH is supporting at
Yale Johns Hopkins University of
Washington in effort to identify the
consequence of mutation of every gene in
the human genome these are going to not
just define the consequence of these
rare mutations but will identify
therapeutic targets for new approaches
to therapeutic intervention in the
general population and then most
recently a President Obama recognizing
the power of this approach in his State
of the Union address this year announced
a precision medicine initiative and this
initiative is to try to develop but even
further this link between genomes
mutations common variations human traits
and had disease outcomes this led to
just think about this for a moment the
path to preventing heart disease where
we've made so much progress over the
last 75 years started with an
epidemiologic study in 1948 in which we
followed several thousand members of the
Framingham community in Massachusetts
and identified which factors years later
where the factors that predicted the
development of heart disease in
individuals and that led to the
recognition of smoking high cholesterol
and hypertension is the major risk
factors for heart disease and we now
have shown that if we reduce smoking
lower cholesterol and lower blood
pressure this has profound effects to
reduce the incidence of heart disease
well the goals of the precision medicine
initiative or to do the same for every
other disease and if goal is to enroll
more than a million Americans to follow
them longitudinally and identify what
factors at the time of enrollment are
predictive of development of virtually
every human disease 5 10
years later so this will be a large
scale at longitudinal cohort study that
will combine genomic technologies the
tablet measurement of many metabolites
measurement of the development disease
measurement of disease outcome a very
large project I get one meters across
many sites across the United States I
had the privilege noted co-chairing the
planning process for this we just
finished this cast and you'll be hearing
more about this as time goes on and this
project begins to get to roll down so we
have as a goal then to determine the
consequence of the occasion of all genes
in the human genome to use this to
identify genes and pathways for the
greatest potential for development of
new diagnostics and therapeutics how
we're going to use DNA sequencing going
forward as a major question I think
there's little question that we'll be
using it to understand the causes of
cancer in individual patients and over a
yield emitted hospital today were
routine with sequencing the genomes of
cancers to determine what are the
specific driver mutations in each cancer
we ought to be able to do a much better
job with newborn screening to identify
at Birth who is has a particular disease
that needs intervention at birth in the
state of Connecticut we have screened
every newborn for 40 different diseases
will be able to do a much better job of
this was DNA sequencing will be
identifying clinical
as I've described will be sequencing for
prenatal diagnosis which is currently
done and the question is will we be
doing genome sequencing of everyone at
birth to determine whole are inherited
susceptibilities disease their potential
pluses to this there are also potential
Highnesses we're not very good at
factoring the odds of disease so if I
tell you your risk of developing
schizophrenia may be increased by a
factor of two well that may sound
terrible until you recognize that your
baseline risk is one percent and if you
double that risk it would only be two
percent so making sure that we are
conveying this kind of information in
ways that actually helps people rather
than increases our neuroses about the
diseases that we are unlikely to ever
get remains a major challenge in the
field and then lastly development of new
technology over the last several years
has provided provided for found
opportunities to develop new methods
that might allow us to actually correct
specific mutations and this is a topic
of its should be a future topic for this
session to discuss in another venue but
is it one of the profound potential
location for how we think about health
and medicine for future generations I
think I'll stop there and thank you very
much